What will make you change? For most of us, it is not self-help books, courses at the learning annex. We are immune to any number of long, sincere talks with our friends about the problems that do not go away. We are immune to resolutions made at the last minute of the last hour of each December 31.
是什么让你做出改变？对我们大多数人来说，不是自助书籍，也不是学习辅导班。我们对朋友关于那些无法解决的问题所做的无数次真诚的长谈已经产生了免疫力。我们对每年12月31日最后一小时所做的决定也已经免疫了。
Consider the story of Evan Harris. She didn't like her job. She wanted to leave her boyfriend. She was living in a city she didn't like.
想想埃文·哈里斯（Evan Harris）的故事。她不喜欢自己的工作。她想离开男朋友。她住在一个她不喜欢的城市。
I was well-entrenched in my life and pretty much sleepwalking.
我当时完全陷在生活中，就像是在梦游一样。
And weeks went by. And months went by. And then one day, she and a coworker were in the mail room at the extremely low-level office jobs that they held, and there amongst the envelopes, stacks of envelopes everywhere, they started talking. And that's where it happened to Evan Harris.
几周过去了。几个月过去了。然后有一天，她和一位同事在她们从事的那份极其底层的工作的收发室里，在一堆堆信封中间，她们聊了起来。埃文·哈里斯的故事就是从那里开始的。
You know how sometimes the smallest thing can end up changing your entire life? A casual comment by somebody that you barely know, an ad you happen to spot in the newspaper, a chance encounter, one little moment. And later when you look back, you realize, oh, that was it. That was the moment. That was the pivot point around which my entire life turned and spun and went into a totally different direction. And you know you don't get to choose. You do not get to choose this pivotal moment. And sometimes, as anybody over a certain age can tell you, the pivotal moment can be kind of stupid.
你知道吗，有时候最小的事情最终会彻底改变你的一生？一个你几乎不认识的人随口说的一句话，你在报纸上碰巧看到的一则广告，一次偶然的相遇，一个小小的时间点。后来当你回首往事时，你会意识到，哦，就是那个。那就是那一刻。那是我的整个生活转向、旋转并进入一个完全不同方向的转折点。而且你知道，你无法选择。你无法选择这个关键时刻。而且正如任何上了年纪的人所能告诉你的那样，这个关键时刻有时候可能相当愚蠢。
In Evan Harris's case, it was about as unlikely as they come.
就埃文·哈里斯的情况而言，这几乎是不可能发生的。
We were doing some sort of menial labor. She was doing a mailing, and I was putting some stuff in alphabetical order. And I said to her, "Shouldn't the letter Q be further toward the back of the alphabet?"
我们当时在做一些苦力。她在发邮件，我在整理一些按字母顺序排列的文件。我对她说：“字母Q不应该排在字母表的后面吗？”
That's it. With the utterance of those words-- let me just play this back for you. Because these are words which changed an adult human life. Here we go.
就是这样。随着那几个词的说出——让我为你重现一下。因为这些话改变了一个成年人的人生。我们开始吧。
"Shouldn't the letter Q be further toward the back of the alphabet?"
“字母Q不应该排在字母表的后面吗？”
With those words, Evan Harris's life took a 180 degree turn.
有了这些话，埃文·哈里斯的人生来了个180度大转弯。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago. This is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Quitting, stories of people who quit everything in their lives that they hated and what happened to them afterwards.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台。这是《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们节目的主题是“退出”，讲述那些退出了生命中所有他们讨厌的事物的人，以及后来发生在他们身上的故事。
Coming up, writer Sandra Tsing Loh, Lisa Buscani, and others. Stay with us.
接下来，作家桑德拉·青·罗（Sandra Tsing Loh）、丽莎·布斯卡尼（Lisa Buscani）等人将登场。请继续收听。
So Evan Harris and her friend and coworker, Shelley Ross, were at this job and they started talking about the letter Q. And it was the kind of conversation you can only really have at a job that does not require total concentration. So you're sorting mail, you're frying burgers, you're doing whatever. And so they're talking about the letter Q.
所以埃文·哈里斯和她的朋友兼同事谢莉·罗斯（Shelley Ross）当时在那份工作中开始讨论字母Q。那是那种只有在不需要完全专注的工作中才能进行的谈话。所以你当时可能在分拣邮件，在炸汉堡，或者做别的什么。于是她们就在讨论字母Q。
And again, remember, this is the pivotal conversation in a person's life. They're talking about the letter Q and they get to talking about where it should be in the alphabet. And in their minds, Q does not belong in the middle of the alphabet where it is, with the hoi polloi of the alphabet. Your Ms, your Ns, your Ps. Letters that will just join any word for the asking. N is in letters-- you don't even hear it. Damn. What's it doing in there?
再次提醒，这是一个人生命中至关重要的谈话。她们在讨论字母Q，然后开始讨论它在字母表中应该排在哪里。在她们看来，Q不应该待在字母表中间的位置，和那些平凡的字母在一起。那些M、N、P。那些随叫随到、加入任何单词的字母。N出现在字母里——你甚至听不到它的存在。该死。它在那儿干什么？
Q, in their mind, has more character. Q, in their mind, doesn't take anything off of anybody. It makes demands and it sees that they are met. What other letter has an adjunct, a bodyguard with it, carried into every word? In their mind, Q belongs at the end of the alphabet, with your Xs, your Ys, your Zs. Letters that do not care what anybody thinks of them and that don't just join up to any word.
在她们看来，Q更有个性。在她们看来，Q从不吃任何人的亏。它提出要求，并确保要求得到满足。还有哪个字母有这种附属物，一个随身携带的保镖，出现在每个单词里？在她们看来，Q应该排在字母表的最后，和X、Y、Z待在一起。那些根本不在乎别人怎么看它们，也不会随便加入任何单词的字母。
And Q, of course, is the first letter of the word "quit." You can't spell "quit" without Q, at least on public radio you can't. And Evan Harris and her friend Shelley Ross started talking about what it means to be able to quit something. What are the qualities that you need? And they decided the qualities were that kind of fierce independence that, in fact, they saw in the letter Q. And they talked about quitting for a long time that day.
当然，Q也是单词“quit”（退出）的第一个字母。你拼不出没有Q的“quit”，至少在公共广播里不行。埃文·哈里斯和她的朋友谢莉·罗斯开始讨论能够退出某件事意味着什么。你需要具备什么样的品质？她们认为这些品质就是那种狂野的独立性，事实上，她们在字母Q身上看到了这一点。那天她们谈了很久的关于退出的事情。
And Quitter Quarterly just came out of my mouth, really. I mean it just came out of my mouth. It kind of came from heaven. It kind of came from heaven. Really. It just kind of lit down on me. And there it was, and that's how I saw it.
“退出季刊”（Quitter Quarterly）这个名字真的是脱口而出。我是说它就这样脱口而出了。它仿佛来自天堂。它仿佛来自天堂。真的。它就像落在我身上一样。名字就这样出现了，我就是这么看到的。
Quitter Quarterly. At that moment, Evan Harris and her friend Shelley Ross decided to publish a little zine, a little Xerox thing, just a couple pages long, called Quitter Quarterly. And that changed Evan's life.
“退出季刊”。在那一刻，埃文·哈里斯和她的朋友谢莉·罗斯决定出版一本小杂志，一种复印的小册子，只有几页长，叫《退出季刊》。这改变了埃文的生活。
Recently I heard about the butter sculptures at the Minnesota State Fair. These are these big sculptures made entirely out of butter. The way it was explained to me was that they are often of the queen for the day. That some teenage girl will be selected as the fair queen that day, and then her bust will be done in butter.
最近我听说了明尼苏达州博览会上的黄油雕塑。这些巨大的雕塑完全是用黄油制成的。向我解释的方式是，它们通常是当天的“黄油皇后”。有些十几岁的女孩会被选为当天的博览会皇后，然后她的半身像就会用黄油做出来。
And it got me to thinking, what if my muse had called me to work in butter? What if my muse said, you will now represent the human form in butter? What if your muse calls you to do something hokey and out-of-date, like singing in coffeehouses or I don't even know. The point is we cannot choose who we fall in love with. We cannot choose what we are interested to write about. We cannot choose our muse.
这让我开始思考，如果我的缪斯女神召唤我去用黄油创作呢？如果我的缪斯说，你现在要用黄油来表现人体呢？如果你的缪斯召唤你去干一些过时又愚蠢的事情，比如在咖啡馆唱歌，或者我甚至不知道是什么。重点是我们无法选择爱上谁。我们无法选择我们有兴趣写什么。我们无法选择我们的缪斯。
And quitting was the muse that called Evan Harris. She had written other things before Quitter Quarterly, but back then the ideas came out in a trickle. When she wrote about quitting, it was like this inexhaustible fountain. It was standing in front of a fire hydrant, immense force, full blast coming at her.
而“退出”就是召唤埃文·哈里斯的缪斯。在《退出季刊》之前她也写过其他东西，但那时创意只是涓涓细流。当她写到“退出”时，就像是一股取之不竭的喷泉。就像站在消防栓前，巨大的力量全速向她袭来。
It really came all at once. I mean, I really sat down to start writing about it, and it really came out. And it seemed to have already been formed.
这真的是一下子就涌现出来了。我是说，我真的坐下来开始写它，然后它就真的写出来了。而且它似乎已经成型了。
And the way that Evan Harris and Shelley Ross write about quitting is so evocative and funny that after just two issues of this tiny little zine, Quitter Quarterly was excerpted in Harper's Magazine and it was named Zine of the Month by Sassy Magazine , which covers your sort of highbrow to lowbrow scale. Soon a publisher had Evan writing a book which is going to be out this coming May called The Quit .
埃文·哈里斯和谢莉·罗斯关于“退出”的写作方式非常引人入胜且风趣，仅仅两期小册子之后，《退出季刊》就被《哈珀杂志》（Harper's Magazine）转载，并被《萨西杂志》（Sassy Magazine）评为“月度杂志”，这涵盖了从高雅到通俗的范围。不久之后，一位出版商就让埃文写了一本书，将于今年五月出版，书名就是《退出》（The Quit）。
And all of this was happening because Evan Harris and Shelley Ross were not just writing about quitting. They were inventing an entire philosophy of quitting, a theory of quitting. Quitter Quarterly is like a scientific inquiry into the properties of quitting. For example, the euphoria of the quit.
这一切之所以发生，是因为埃文·哈里斯和谢莉·罗斯不仅在写关于退出的事。她们正在发明一整套退出的哲学，一种退出的理论。《退出季刊》就像是对退出属性的科学探究。例如，退出的快感。
The euphoria of the quit. Quitting euphoria is an incredible thing. I don't know how much you have quit, but there is an incredible charge to quitting that is like a drug. It's like being in love kind of, except it's being in love with your decision.
退出的快感。退出的快感是一件不可思议的事情。我不知道你退出了多少事情，但退出有一种令人难以置信的冲击力，就像毒品一样。就像坠入爱河一样，只不过你是爱上了你自己的决定。
Evan Harris was writing about quitting, and thinking about quitting, and gathering the strength to quit her job and her boyfriend and her city, which, by the way, she did. And at some point in this entire process, her view of the world began to change. Quits and potential quits seemed to be everywhere. She would go out with a friend for coffee and, of course, talk about all this quitting business that she was thinking about all the time. And then this friend, no matter who it was, would come out with some story about something that he or she wanted to quit. Quitting started to seem like the engine that made everything in the world go round.
埃文·哈里斯一直在写关于退出，思考关于退出，并聚集力量去辞掉工作、离开男朋友和她所在的城市，顺便说一句，她确实做了。在这个整个过程中，她对世界的看法开始改变。退出和潜在的退出似乎无处不在。她会和朋友出去喝咖啡，当然会谈论她一直思考的这些退出事宜。然后这位朋友，无论他是谁，都会讲出一些他或她想要退出的事情。退出开始看起来像是推动世界上一切运转的引擎。
The way I see it in thinking about my own life, I see it as being framed and the narrative of it being pushed along by quitting, by quits. So that my first big quit was to leave the college that I was going to, and I moved to New York City. And then my next big quit was to quit the graduate program that I was in, and then I fell into this job. And so now I have nothing left to quit. I mean I've quit my boyfriend. I've quit my city. I've quit my job. And I have nothing left to quit. And so really now there's nothing to do but build things up again. Do you see what I mean?
在我思考自己的人生时，我看待它的方式是，它被退出所构建，它的叙事被退出所推动。所以我的第一次大退出就是退学，然后我搬到了纽约市。然后我的下一次大退出就是退出了我在读的研究生课程，然后我碰巧得到了这份工作。所以现在我没什么可退出的了。我是说，我退出了我的男朋友。我退出了我的城市。我退出了我的工作。我再也没有什么可退出的了。所以现在真的只能再次从头建立起一切。你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah, but you say that as if you're just building them up for what will be the central fact of your life, which is then you're going to quit them.
是的，但你说的好像你建立它们只是为了你生命中的核心事实，即你之后会再次退出它们一样。
That's right. The way I see it is that there's sort of like two basic, big, important concepts. OK? And the first one is that nothing lasts forever. There is nothing that you can do that you can keep on doing forever. Nothing. That's it. Period. End of story. And then the other big one is that you have to be doing something. So my feeling is it's better to willfully quit whatever it is and then go on to the next thing that you have to be doing, because you have to be doing something, than to just kind of let things fall apart.
没错。我的看法是，这里有两个基本的、巨大的、重要的概念。好吗？第一，没有什么东西是永恒的。没有什么事情是你做了一次就能永远做下去的。没有。就是这样。句号。故事结束。另一个重要的概念是，你必须在做某件事。所以我感觉，与其让事情崩溃，不如主动退出当前的事情，然后去做下一件你必须做的事，因为你总得做点什么。
The quitting cycle. In everybody's life, there is something of a quitting cycle. So you can talk about adolescence being a time where people quit listening to their parents. And then maybe in people's mid-to-late 20s, they start quitting places or even quitting people. And then later on in mid-life, I think that there's a little bit of a quitting thing going on, which some people call mid-life crisis, and I would probably call it the mid-life quit. And then for older adults, I think they do quite a bit of quitting, too. I think that they basically quit giving a damn what people think of them and quit worrying about certain things.
退出周期。在每个人的生命中，都存在着某种退出周期。所以你可以说青春期是一个人们开始停止听从父母建议的时期。然后可能在人们20多岁到快30岁时，他们开始退出某些地方，甚至退出某些人。再后来到了中年，我认为也会发生一点点退出，有些人称之为中年危机，而我可能会称之为“中年退出”。然后对于老年人，我认为他们也退出了不少事情。我认为他们基本上退出了对别人看法的在意，退出了对某些事情的担忧。
There's the quitting cycle and then there's the nature of quitters, which I think is important. I don't think quitters are lazy people necessarily. I mean some quitters are probably lazy, but I don't think that the essential nature of a quitter is to be lazy. I think that the essential nature of a quitter is to be able to cut their losses and move on. Quitting is about being willful. Quitting is about having one's own volition to do whatever.
有退出周期，还有退出者的本质，我认为这很重要。我不认为退出者一定是懒人。我是说，有些退出者可能确实懒，但我不认为退出者的基本本质就是懒。我认为退出者的基本本质是能够及时止损并继续前进。退出是关于自主。退出是拥有按照自己意愿行事的意志。
Can I ask you to reflect on why it is that you think the word "quitter" has such a pejorative connotation in our culture? Because I think of the last time I saw the word "quitter" and it was a cover of a magazine with Ross Perot on it, when he pulled out of the presidential race. And the word "quitter" was above him. Just the notion of being a quitter was so shameful. That was the message of it.
我可以请你反思一下，为什么“退出者”这个词在我们的文化中有如此贬义的含义吗？因为我想起我最后一次看到“退出者”这个词是在一期杂志封面上，罗斯·佩罗（Ross Perot）退选总统的时候。那个词就写在他头顶。仅仅作为“退出者”的观念就如此可耻。这就是它传达的信息。
The word "quitter" does have a negative connotation, and that's something that I would really like to change. I would really like to kidnap that word. I see quitters as people who have volition. Quitters never win and winners never quit, and that's completely untrue. I mean really the more things you quit, the more things you're going to do. And the more things you do, the more potential you have for success.
“退出者”这个词确实有负面含义，这真的是我想要改变的事情。我真的很想重新定义这个词。我将退出者视为有意志力的人。人们常说“退出者永不赢，赢家永不退”，这完全是不对的。我是说，实际上你退出的事情越多，你做的事情就越多。而你做的事情越多，你成功的潜力就越大。
I mean, I would say that Quitter Quarterly as a thing is definitely pro-quitting propaganda. I mean, absolutely. But I'm not so much describing-- well, maybe I'm describing a little bit what quits feel like. But I'm much more interested in the anatomy of quitting. I would say that the anatomy of an actual quit would vary, but the general form of a quit would be that the quitter thinks about it. The quitter thinks about it some more. The quitter quits. And then there's the post-quitting stuff.
我是说，我会说《退出季刊》本质上绝对是支持退出的宣传品。我是说，绝对是。但我描述的不是——好吧，也许我稍微描述了一点退出是什么感觉。但我对退出的剖析更感兴趣。我会说，实际退出的解剖结构会有所不同，但退出的通用形式是，退出者思考它。退出者再多思考一下。退出者退出。然后是退出后的事情。
I'm just going to stop that right there. Are you following this particular point? Let's review those steps again, OK? The anatomy of a quit. The quitter thinks about it. Step two now. The quitter thinks about it some more. To me this indicates somebody who actually has been in that position. You don't just think about it. It goes on for a really long, long time before you actually then do the quit. Let's review.
我先停在这里。你跟上这个特定的观点了吗？让我们再回顾一下那些步骤，好吗？退出的解剖结构。退出者思考它。现在是第二步。退出者再多思考一下。对我来说，这表明某人确实处于那种境地。你不仅仅是思考它。在真正付诸行动之前，这往往会持续很长很长的时间。让我们回顾一下。
That the quitter thinks about it. The quitter thinks about it some more. The quitter quits. And then there's the post-quitting stuff.
退出者思考它。退出者再多思考一下。退出者退出。然后是退出后的事情。
Now, you know, we have all met in our lives people who have come to see the world through a single idea, people for whom all interaction can be explained by some scheme. And it could be a big idea. It could be the laws of supply and demand, or Fundamentalist Christianity, or structuralist linguistic theory. Or it could be a small idea. The need for everybody to do aerobic exercise on a regular basis, or the danger of fluoridation, or CIA conspiracies dating back to the Bay of Pigs.
现在，你知道，我们在生活中都遇到过那些通过单一观点来看待世界的人，对他们来说，所有的互动都可以用某种模式来解释。这可能是一个宏大的构想。可能是供需法则，或是基督教原教旨主义，或者是结构主义语言学理论。也可能是一个微小的想法。每个人定期做有氧运动的必要性，或者氟化的危险，或者是追溯到猪湾事件的中情局阴谋。
Who amongst us has not had a conversation on a train, or a plane, or at a party, or an in-law's house, where some earnest-faced person, full of evidence and theory, expounds at length on an idea like, if everyone on the earth would just stand on his or her head for an hour a day, there would be world peace?
我们中间谁没在火车上、飞机上、聚会上或亲戚家里进行过这样的谈话：某个一脸认真、充满证据和理论的人，长篇大论地阐述一个想法，比如“如果地球上的每个人每天能倒立一个小时，世界就会和平”？
And if you talk to Evan Harris for a while, she'll tell you about the great quits which have driven world history, how, in fact, all the wars and strife of the millennia are, in fact, better understood as a series of quits. And as some people will do when they become obsessed with a single topic, she sometimes delves into quitting issues that are so esoteric, so erudite, that it would be hard, I think, for anyone else to not just understand them, but to care about them.
如果你和埃文·哈里斯聊上一会儿，她会告诉你驱动世界历史的那些伟大的退出，事实上，几千年来所有的战争和冲突，实际上可以更好地理解为一系列的退出。正如某些人沉迷于单一主题时所做的那样，她有时会深入研究那些极其深奥、极其博学的退出问题，我想，对其他人来说，不仅难以理解，而且难以关心。
For example, she was trying to figure out a system for how to rate the importance of various types of quits. She actually created a mathematical model to do that that she was working on. And during our interview, she repeated several times that quitting had a life of its own, a life separate from any of the quits that you might make or I might make or other people make. In her mind, it seemed that quitting-- was almost like a living thing, separate from the actions of human beings.
例如，她试图找出一种评定各种类型退出重要性的系统。她实际上为此创造了一个数学模型。在我们的采访中，她多次重申，退出本身有自己的生命，独立于你、我或其他人可能做出的任何退出行为。在她的头脑中，似乎“退出”——几乎像是一个有生命的个体，独立于人类的行为。
Quitting itself has an identity, and your particular quit, one quitter's particular quit, fits into the world and all the other quitters in the world. And you have to remember that your quit is going to influence another person's quit, potentially. The point of quitting is to move in the world and to get bigger and bigger as a person. God damn. Sometimes I just start to sound like a nut basically about this. I mean, what am I talking about? What am I talking about? You have to understand. This is so on my mind. I think about this all the time. I think about this all the time. I'm thinking about getting up and walking out of this room right now. I really am.
退出本身有一个身份，而你的特定退出，一个退出者的特定退出，适合这个世界和其他所有的退出者。你必须记住，你的退出可能会影响另一个人的退出。退出的意义在于在世界中前行，并作为一个个体变得越来越强大。该死。有时我基本上开始听起来像个疯子。我是说，我在说什么？我在说什么？你必须理解。这件事一直在我的脑海里。我一直都在想这个。我一直在想这个。我现在就在想站起来走出这个房间。真的。
Quitting is not just about how it feels to yourself. No, I don't think that's true. I don't think that's true. And I think that people have to see themselves in a swim that way.
退出不仅关乎你自己有什么感觉。不，我不认为那是真的。我不认为那是真的。而且我认为人们必须以那种方式看待自己。
In a swim of quitting?
在退出的浪潮中？
In a swim of quitting.
在退出的浪潮中。
In a swim of quitting with other swimmers, with other people who are quitting?
在和其他游泳者，和其他正在退出的人一起的退出浪潮中？
Right.
没错。
Evan, I have to say that you're saying people should be aware of themselves as being part of a world of quitting, and a world of people who are quitting, and a whole idea of the notion of quitting. But I have to say, in all of my life, you are the only person I've ever met who thinks of it that way.
埃文，我必须说，你说人们应该意识到自己是退出世界的一部分，是退出者世界的一部分，以及退出观念的一部分。但我必须说，在我这一生中，你是唯一一个以这种方式思考的人。
Oh, but you're so wrong about that. Oh well, maybe you're not wrong. Am I really the only person you've ever met who thinks of quitting in this way?
哦，但你在这点上太错了。哦好吧，也许你没错。我真的是你见过的唯一一个以这种方式思考退出的人吗？
You yourself said you didn't start to think about quitting in this way before February.
你自己说过，你不是在二月份之前开始这样思考退出的。
Right, but just because I didn't start to think about it before February doesn't mean that no one else has ever thought of it before.
没错，但仅仅因为我在二月份之前没有开始思考它，并不意味着没有其他人曾经思考过它。
I wonder how long you're going to feel this way, how long you're going to be this interested in quitting.
我很好奇你会这样想多久，你对退出的兴趣会持续多久。
I don't know how long I'll be interested in quitting. I think maybe what you're suggesting is that I'll get it out of my system and I'll be over it and it'll be done. But as I said before, I have quit everything. I don't, in a very literal way, have anything to quit anymore. I have no city. I have no boyfriend. I have no home. Not that those are the only things in life. I mean, I suppose I could quit smoking or quit eating things that are bad for me. There's a lot of little quits that I could execute which I might do just to tide me over. But the thing about quitting is that it runs on a cycle so that now or soon-- not quite yet-- but soon, I'll be building more things up which I will quit.
我不知道我会对退出感兴趣多久。我想你可能是在暗示我会把它从我的系统中排出去，我会超越它，一切就结束了。但正如我之前所说，我已经退出了所有的事情。在非常字面的意义上，我不再有什么可退出的了。我没有城市。我没有男朋友。我没有家。并不是说那些是生活中的唯一事物。我是说，我想我可以戒烟或者停止吃对我不好的东西。我可以执行很多小型的退出，我可能会做这些事来撑过一段时间。但退出的事情在于它是按周期运行的，所以现在或不久之后——还不完全是现在——但我很快就会建立起更多的事情，然后我会把它们退出。
Are you sure?
你确定吗？
Yes, I am sure.
是的，我确定。
Evan Harris. If you would like a copy of Quitter Quarterly , get a pencil. It's P.O. Box 20515, Tompkins Square Station, New York, New York, 10009. Again. Quitter Quarterly , P.O. Box 20515, Tompkins Square Station, New York, New York, 10009. A copy is $0.25 plus the cost of one thin American stamp.
埃文·哈里斯。如果你想要一份《退出季刊》，拿支铅笔。邮政信箱20515，汤普金斯广场分局，纽约，纽约州，10009。再次说明。《退出季刊》，邮政信箱20515，汤普金斯广场分局，纽约，纽约州，10009。一份费用为0.25美元加上一张美国薄邮票的费用。
Well, coming up in a minute, all the dogs in a suburban Los Angeles neighborhood quit their dull, suburban lives. Stay with us.
好的，一分钟后，洛杉矶郊区的所有狗都退出了它们枯燥、郊区的生活。请继续收听。
[MUSIC - "DON'T FENCE ME IN" BY ELLA FITZGERALD]
[音乐 - 艾拉·费兹杰拉德演唱的《别圈住我》]
This is Sandra Tsing Loh in Los Angeles, sitting at the piano, and this is a story about quitting.
我是洛杉矶的桑德拉·青·罗，坐在钢琴前，这是一个关于退出的故事。
Right now it is at that moment of the day, that sour, late afternoon moment, when the orangey rays of the fading afternoon sun slant across patches of-- not exactly lawn, but a kind of leathery Bermuda clover that springs up in the West Valley after the rain. And a dog realizes that his world is not a swirling universe of endless possibility, of good and evil, of constantly banging up against the portals of Blakean excess. But it is a 10x15 foot yard with a locked gate at the end. And your kibble isn't even the good kibble. It's the Lady Lee bargain kibble. And the only reason to get up in the morning is to chase a blue rubber ball with a bell in it.
现在正是这一天的那一刻，那个酸涩、迟到的下午时刻，当夕阳微弱的橙色光芒斜射在——不完全是草坪，而是一种雨后在西谷长出的皮革般的百慕大草地上。一只狗意识到，他的世界不是一个充满无限可能、善恶共存、不断撞击布莱克式过度世界大门的漩涡宇宙。而是一个尽头有锁着的门的10x15英尺的院子。你的狗粮甚至不是好狗粮。那是莉·李（Lady Lee）便宜货狗粮。早起唯一的理由就是追一个带铃铛的蓝色橡胶球。
And life seems as drab and dry as dust, at least so it seems today to two particular dogs-- Joey, a large silver-haired Australian Shepherd with no tail but a wagging skirt, and his companion, Flipper, of a German Shepherd-Terrier mix, which makes him small and yappy. But then, at that moment, Joey and Flipper hear this magical call.
生活看起来像灰尘一样单调干燥，至少对于两只特定的狗来说今天是这样——乔伊（Joey），一只毛色银亮、没有尾巴但有摆动长毛的澳大利亚牧羊犬，以及他的同伴，弗利珀（Flipper），一只德国牧羊犬和梗犬的混血，这让他看起来又小又爱叫。但就在那一刻，乔伊和弗利珀听到了那声神奇的召唤。
It is Rusty and Boots, the neighborhood dog sentinels. Excitedly, they are barking out a message. "There's something going on in the alley. There's something going on in the alley." One by one, each other dog in the neighborhood-- Ginger and Patches and Blueberry and Joey and Flipper-- bolt to their back gates, trying to press their moist noses through the wooden slats to see what's going on as they raise their voices in a joyous canine cacophony.
那是锈斑（Rusty）和靴子（Boots），社区的狗哨兵。它们兴奋地吠叫着一条信息。“巷子里有动静。巷子里有动静。”一只又一只社区里的狗——姜饼（Ginger）、补丁（Patches）、蓝莓（Blueberry）还有乔伊和弗利珀——冲向它们的后门，试图把湿漉漉的鼻子挤过木板缝，看看发生了什么，同时它们的声音汇成了一场快乐的犬类喧嚣。
And indeed, there in the alley it is the most famous dog of all time, Buck, the Husky from Jack London's Call of the Wild . He stands effortlessly on his hind legs, his ruff is beautifully fluffed, and in kind of a debonair, Howard Keel-type way, he sings in shimmering tenor, "Come, you dogs. Come, you doggies. Come, you dogs. Come to Canada. Canada. Big mountains, big valleys, big sky, big water. It's Marlboro country."
事实上，在巷子里的正是史上最著名的狗，巴克（Buck），杰克·伦敦《野性的呼唤》中的那只哈士奇。他毫不费力地用后腿站立，脖子上的毛蓬松得漂亮极了，以一种优雅的、像霍华德·基尔（Howard Keel）风格的样子，用闪烁的男高音唱道：“来吧，你们这些狗。来吧，狗狗们。来吧，你们这些狗。去加拿大吧。加拿大。大山，大峡谷，大天空，大水。那是万宝路的世界。”
Joey and Flipper can almost hear the National Geographic theme playing. It is the sound of 2,000 Maasai warriors, hirpling across the desert with their spears pointing of the mysterious curve of the horn of the wildebeest and of the water buffalo, of the veiled gaze of a red-nostriled mandrill monkey. It is so exciting that, one by one, the dogs overleap their back gates, which used to be impossible, but now seems ridiculously easy. There goes Ginger and Patches and Blueberry and Rusty and Boots and Flipper!
乔伊和弗利珀几乎能听到《国家地理》的主题曲在播放。那是2000名马赛武士的声音，他们拖着长矛走过沙漠，指向角马和水牛角的神秘曲线，以及红鼻猴那隐晦的凝视。这太令人兴奋了，一只又一只，狗们跳过了它们的后门，这过去是不可能的，但现在看起来却简单得荒谬。姜饼、补丁、蓝莓、锈斑、靴子还有弗利珀都去了！
"Come, you dogs. Come, you doggies. Come, you dogs. Come on. And Joey! And Joey."
“来吧，你们这些狗。来吧，狗狗们。来吧，你们这些狗。快点。还有乔伊！还有乔伊。”
And Joey, who at this humiliating moment cannot quite get his lardy, overweight body, stuffed full of too many Cheetos and Doritos quite over that back gate. Buck has to athletically leap behind and push against his big behind, as though it were one of Yul Brynner's obelisks in The Ten Commandments.
而乔伊，在这个尴尬的时刻，无法让那肥胖的、装满了太多奇多和多力多滋的沉重身体翻过那扇后门。巴克不得不敏捷地跳到后面，推着他那庞大的屁股，就像推着尤尔·伯连纳（Yul Brynner）在《十诫》里的方尖碑一样。
And Joey's over. And his skirt lifts out behind him like a magic cape. And he and the other dogs are sailing, flying over the San Fernando Valley. For the first time, they look down at the humming suburban grid that was outside that back gate the whole time.
乔伊翻过去了。他那长毛像魔法披风一样在他身后扬起。他和其它狗一起在圣费尔南多谷上空航行、飞翔。这是它们第一次俯瞰那一直存在于后门外的嗡嗡作响的郊区网格。
The slowly revolving orange and yellow sign of the Canoga Park Motor Inn, Canoga Park Bowl. Canoga Park Motor Inn, Canoga Park Bowl. Canoga Park Motor Inn, Canoga Park Bowl-- and the Yoshinoya Beef Bowl. And the Winnetka 5 Drive-in movie theater, which is playing Nightmare on Elm Street Part 5 again.
卡诺加公园汽车旅馆、卡诺加保龄球馆缓慢旋转的橙色和黄色标志。卡诺加公园汽车旅馆、卡诺加保龄球馆。卡诺加公园汽车旅馆、卡诺加保龄球馆——还有吉野家牛肉饭。以及温内特卡5号汽车电影院，正在重播《猛鬼街5》。
And Roscoe and [? Sadequois, ?] those harsh West Valley speedways over which grimy King Auto Bear shops glower. And the yellow ranch-style houses with their balding lawns, whose occupants keep using the drought as an excuse for letting everything go to pot. Occupants who eek out their sad, daily lives of quiet desperation. Prisoners of the People Magazine demographics which enslave them. Their favorite TV shows being blank cyphers, like Full House and Empty Nest . And never, in the history of Western civilization, has the nest seemed quite so empty as it does today.
还有罗斯科和那些粗糙的西谷高速公路，骯脏的国王汽车修理店在上面阴森俯视。还有那些有着秃顶草坪的黄色牧场式住宅，住户们总是以干旱为借口让一切荒废。住户们在安静的绝望中过着他们悲哀的日常生活。那是奴役他们的《人物杂志》人口统计的囚徒。他们最喜欢的电视节目是像《满屋》和《空巢》这样的空白密码。在西方文明史上，巢穴从来没有像今天这样显得如此空洞。
But to the dogs, the suburban grid is the most fascinating thing they've ever seen. "But you think that's amazing," says Buck. "Wait 'til you are skimming with me over the ice flows of the Arctic tundra and all around you snowy mountain peaks are raising like cathedral spires. And the air is clean, Zestfully clean and manly and good." And with that, as if in a Spielberg film, the dogs sail away from it all, over the Angeles Crest mountains, disappearing in a burst of a magical star shower. Night is falling, adventure calling. Night is falling, adventure calling.
但对狗来说，郊区的网格是它们见过的最迷人的东西。“但你们认为那很神奇，”巴克说。“等你们和我一起滑过北极苔原的冰原，周围所有的雪山山峰像大教堂尖顶一样升起。空气洁净，充满活力，像男人一样好。”说完，仿佛在斯皮尔伯格的电影中一样，狗群飞离了一切，飞过安吉利斯克雷斯特山脉，消失在一阵神奇的星雨中。夜幕降临，冒险在召唤。夜幕降临，冒险在召唤。
[MUSIC - "DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT (DISAPPEAR)" BY BRAVE COMBO]
[音乐 - 勇敢组合（Brave Combo）演唱的《做点不同的事情（消失）》]
Lisa Buscani and more coming up. It's Your Radio Playhouse.
丽莎·布斯卡尼和更多精彩内容即将到来。这里是《你的广播剧场》。
It is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. All right, let's review. The stages of quitting according to Ms. Evan Harris, editor, co-writer of Quitter Quarterly . The stages of quitting. You think about it. You think about it some more. Then maybe you quit. Maybe you feel that quitting euphoria as you soar over the suburbs with your doggy friends towards Canada. But I think that it is just as likely that you do not quit. I think it's just as likely that you stay suspended in a kind of long-term, pre-quitting confusion for weeks and months. When is it time to quit? When is enough enough?
这里是《你的广播剧场》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。好的，让我们回顾一下。根据《退出季刊》的编辑、合著者埃文·哈里斯女士提出的退出阶段。退出阶段。你思考它。你再多思考一下。然后也许你退出。也许当你和你的狗朋友们一起飞越郊区奔向加拿大时，你会感受到那种退出的快感。但我认为你很有可能根本不会退出。我认为你同样可能陷入一种长期的、退出前的混乱状态，持续数周甚至数月。什么时候是退出的时候？什么时候才算够了？
Go ahead. If you try to touch me, I will kill you in a [BLEEP] minute. In a [BLEEP] minute. Not one minute. 30 seconds.
来吧。如果你试着碰我，我会在一分钟内杀了你。在一分钟内。不到一分钟。30秒。
If there ever was a couple that seemed like it should quit its relationship, I would say that this one would pretty much qualify. This is Ray, the voice you just heard, and he lived for years with a guy named Peter. And these are real people. And this comes from a very unusual CD that I have here called Shut Up, Little Man . It's called that because one of them is always saying to the other one, "Shut up, little man." And the recordings were made by the next-door neighbors of Raymond and Peter. This all happened in San Francisco in the late 1980s. And as they say in the liner notes, the apartment building this took place in was built like a cheap motel and had very thin walls. I'm just going to read this.
如果曾经有一对情侣看起来应该退出他们的关系，我会说这一对完全符合条件。这是雷（Ray），你刚才听到的声音，他和另一个叫彼得（Peter）的家伙一起住了多年。这些人是真实存在的。这来自我这里一张非常不同寻常的CD，叫《闭嘴，小矮子》（Shut Up, Little Man）。之所以叫这个名字，是因为他们其中一人总是对另一个说：“闭嘴，小矮子。”这些录音是由雷蒙德和彼得的隔壁邻居录制的。这一切发生在20世纪80年代末的旧金山。正如他们在唱片内页说明中所说，发生这件事的公寓楼建得像个廉价汽车旅馆，墙壁非常薄。我就直接读一下这个。
This is the neighbors writing. "Within a week of arrival, we were exposed to what would become a dependable routine from our next-door neighbors. Evenings charged with belligerent rants, hateful harangues, drunken soliloquies, death threats, and the sound of wrestling bodies thumping against the wall that separated our apartments. They fought with a raging abandon and total disregard for everyone in the building."
这是邻居们写的。“入住一周内，我们就暴露在隔壁邻居那种成为固定程序的日常生活中了。夜晚充斥着好斗的咆哮、仇恨的长篇大论、醉酒的独白、死亡威胁，以及身体撞击公寓隔墙的砰砰声。他们以一种狂暴的放纵和对大楼里每个人的完全无视进行争斗。”
The two guys, the neighbors who moved in-- Eddie Lee Sausage and Mitchell D. are their names. They started taping Raymond and Peter. And at first, they just did this because they really thought that at some point somebody might try to kill somebody else, and they thought it would be important to have real evidence. Again, they say in the liner notes, "The first crudely-recorded session featured a monologue by Ray muttering to himself about his desire to kill. There was something so nakedly sinister about the recording that we were shocked, mystified. At the same time, it instilled in us a hunger for more."
搬进来的那两个邻居——埃迪·李·香肠（Eddie Lee Sausage）和米切尔·D.（Mitchell D.）是他们的名字。他们开始录下雷蒙德和彼得的声音。起初，他们这么做只是因为他们真的认为在某个时候可能会有人试图杀死对方，他们认为保留真实的证据很重要。他们再次在内页说明中写道：“第一次粗糙录制的片段里，雷自言自语地嘀咕着想杀人的愿望。录音中有一种如此赤裸裸的邪恶，以至于我们感到震惊、困惑。同时，它也在我们心中种下了一种渴望，渴望听到更多。”
So these two guys-- names of Eddie Lee Sausage and Mitchell D.-- who made these recordings, say that they actually never figured out if Raymond and Peter were a gay couple or if they were just straight roommates. It is clear that homosexuality is on the minds of Raymond and Peter a lot, a whole lot. An unusual amount of time on the CD to rants about how much they hate gays. Raymond and Peter, that is. They rant about this so much that you really began to wonder, what is this obsession about? What is it about? You get that kind of methinks-the-lady-protest-too-much sort of feeling very early on. But I digress.
所以这两个制作录音的家伙——埃迪·李·香肠和米切尔·D.——说他们其实从来没搞清楚雷蒙德和彼得是一对同性恋情侣还是仅仅是直男室友。显而易见，同性恋的问题在雷蒙德和彼得的脑海中占了很大一部分。CD里有异常多的时间在咆哮他们有多讨厌同性恋。我是说雷蒙德和彼得。他们对此咆哮得如此之多，以至于你真的开始怀疑，这种痴迷是什么？这是为了什么？你很早就有了那种“我觉得那个人抗议得太过分了”的感觉。但我离题了。
I bring it here onto this, our Radio Playhouse radio program today, because it includes warning signs about when it is time to quit a relationship, I think. The thing about this couple is that they get into a kind of fight that only very well-established couples or roommates or people who work together get into. And that is it's a fight which begins with the smallest fact of daily life. They literally actually get into a fight about cutting their toenails. And then suddenly everything is riding on cutting their toenails. Everybody's pride. Everybody's self-image. Everything is on the table with this life or death ferocity. When you find yourself in that situation, it's time to start thinking about, maybe I should quit this relationship.
我把它带到我们今天的广播节目中，是因为我认为它包含了何时应该退出一段关系的警告信号。这对情侣的事情在于，他们陷入了一种只有非常成熟的情侣、室友或同事才会陷入的争吵。那就是，这种争吵始于日常生活中的最小事实。他们实际上真的因为修脚指甲而争吵。然后突然间，一切都取决于修脚指甲。每个人的自尊。每个人的自我形象。所有的东西都摆在桌面上，带着这种生死的凶猛。当你发现自己处于那种境地时，是时候开始考虑，也许我应该退出这段关系了。
I can see you trying to cut your toenails. I don't want to see you cut your toenails. So why would I worry about it? For god's sake, shut up, little man. I don't want to watch you cut your toenails.
我能看到你在尝试修你的脚指甲。我不想看你修脚指甲。所以我为什么要担心它？看在上帝的份上，闭嘴，小矮子。我不想看你修脚指甲。
I would like to have eaten tonight also, but I can't because of you talking about toenails.
我今晚也想吃饭，但我不能，因为你在谈论脚指甲。
You know, we've been trying to watch this TV show. Can't we watch it?
你知道，我们一直想看这个电视节目。我们就不能看吗？
Why should you watch this, you [BLEEP] piece of [BLEEP]? All you are is a [BLEEP] queer mother [BLEEP] and you want to watch queer [BLEEP]. I don't want to watch that [BLEEP]. Don't do that. Do not do that.
你为什么要看这个，你这[哔]东西？你不过是个[哔]同性恋，还想看同性恋[哔]。我才不想看那种[哔]。别这样。不要那样做。
What do you want us to do? [INTERPOSING VOICES] We're watching Wheel of Fortune ,  just--
你想让我们干嘛？[嘈杂的人声] 我们在看《幸运轮》，只是——
You watch a bunch of [BLEEP] queer mother [BLEEP]. I don't want to watch queer mother [BLEEP]. I want to watch something decent, like--
你就看那一堆[哔]同性恋烂货。我不想看同性恋烂货。我想看点正经的，比如——
Sorry. Go somewhere else and watch it then. Don't touch-
抱歉。那你去别处看吧。别碰——
Don't you touch me. You were the one that put your hands on me. Don't do that. Get the [BLEEP] out. Get your [BLEEP] hands off me, you [BLEEP].
别碰我。是你先对我动手的。别那样做。给我[哔]滚出去。把你[哔]的手从我身上拿开，你这[哔]。
You go sit down.
你去坐下。
You better get your hands off me.
你最好把你的手从我身上拿开。
Get your hands off that television.
把你的手从那台电视机上拿开。
You go to hell!
你下地狱去吧！
I smell like a human being. You smell like a [BLEEP] dog. You are a dog. I took a bath today. You ain't took a bath in three days.
我闻起来像个人。你闻起来像条[哔]狗。你就是条狗。我今天洗澡了。你都三天没洗澡了。
You just stop it.
你快住口吧。
You're a stinking [BLEEP] piece of [BLEEP]. Dirty man, go to the bathroom.
你是个臭烘烘的[哔]东西。脏男人，去厕所吧。
[GIGGLING]
[咯咯笑]
No, they don't. Go ahead and giggle. Giggle all you want to! Giggle. Giggle, dirty little man. You always giggle falsely. You don't have a decent giggle in you.
不，他们才不。尽管笑吧。想笑就笑个够吧！笑啊。笑吧，肮脏的小男人。你总是假笑。你肚子里一点像样的笑声都没有。
I am a decent--
我是个正经的——
Shut up, little man.
闭嘴，小男人。
I am a decent [BLEEP] human being.
我是个正经的[哔]人。
Shut up, little man. You are not.
闭嘴，小男人。你才不是。
Why don't these guys quit each other? I think part of it-- and I actually think one of the most striking things about these recordings-- is the intimacy of these arguments. Arguing can be one of the most intimate things that people can do together. It's this mutually shared moment.
为什么这些人不离开彼此呢？我认为部分原因——我确实认为这些录音中最引人注目的地方之一——是这些争吵的亲密感。争吵可能是人们能一起做的最亲密的事情之一。这是一种共同分享的时刻。
I'm going to play you one more cut that really illustrates this in a kind of-- I don't know if "chilling" is the right word, but it's disturbing. In the middle of a big argument, one of them is so inside the other one's head and knows so much about him that, at one point, to humiliate him, he starts to call him women's names.
我要再给你们放一段录音，它非常生动地说明了这一点，我不知道“令人不寒而栗”这个词是否合适，但它确实让人不安。在激烈的争吵中，其中一个人对另一个人的心思了如指掌，以至于为了羞辱对方，他开始用女性的名字称呼他。
Try it. Try it, Mabel.
试试啊。试试啊，梅布尔。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
OK, Mabel. I don't attack. I don't attack, Mabel.
好吧，梅布尔。我不攻击。我不攻击，梅布尔。
I'll kill you.
我要杀了你。
OK, Mabel. Try.
好吧，梅布尔。试试吧。
You ain't nothing but a [BLEEP] piece of [BLEEP].
你不过是个[哔]烂货。
Try, Mabel. Try, Mabel.
试试啊，梅布尔。试试啊，梅布尔。
You try to attack me, I'll kill you.
你敢攻击我，我就杀了你。
Try, Alice.
试试啊，爱丽丝。
Don't call me Alice.
别叫我爱丽丝。
All right. What do you think of Mabel? You try.
好吧。你觉得梅布尔怎么样？你试试。
Don't try to tempt me.
别试图诱惑我。
You try and you're going to be done. I'm not going to attack you.
你敢尝试，你就完了。我不会攻击你的。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
I am waiting for you right here.
我就在这儿等着你。
I came here!
我到这儿来了！
Don't be a fool. Don't be a fool, little man.
别犯傻了。别犯傻了，小男人。
I've told you that you're a--
我告诉过你，你是个——
OK, Alice. OK, Julie. Go back in there.
好吧，爱丽丝。好吧，朱莉。回到那儿去。
I have already proved that I'm--
我已经证明了我——
No, you haven't proven anything, Sally.
不，你什么都没证明，莎莉。
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
[听不清的短语]
Sally June, Abigail May, this is just too much.
莎莉·琼，阿比盖尔·梅，这简直太过分了。
You [BLEEP] piece of [BLEEP].
你这[哔]烂货。
You can't take nobody. You're a sick little man.
你谁也对付不了。你是个心理变态的小男人。
I am healthy.
我很健康。
You're a sick little man--
你是个心理变态的小男人——
You're a [BLEEP].
你是个[哔]。
--who is dying from the same thing your brother died of.
——死于你兄弟死于的那种病。
Bull [BLEEP].
放[哔]。
The utter cruelty of that last comment is just breathtaking. They do talk about leaving each other on the CD, but they never do leave each other. As Evan Harris says, the stages of quitting. OK. You think about it. You think it some more. Sometimes you quit. And in their case, you just keep thinking about it some more.
最后那句话的残酷程度简直令人窒息。他们在光盘里确实谈到了离开彼此，但他们从未真正离开。正如埃文·哈里斯所说的，放弃的各个阶段。好吧。你想想看。再多想一想。有时你真的会放弃。而对他们来说，你只是不断地多想一会儿。
Part one, Work.
第一部分，工作。
The morning began with weight. My head sown down to an unbearably heavy burden, pinned to the narcotic pillow. My eyes like their lids shut. Blindness would hinder my motion. My arms and legs remembered the heavy metal burned into their sense memory and refused me the grace I needed to get through the day. My body's refusal to function was in the name of survival. If I moved, that meant I would get up. If I got up, I would probably take a shower and get dressed. If I did that, I would go to work, to unspeakable, unthinkable horror.
早晨带着沉重感开始。我的头耷拉着，承受着无法忍受的重负，被钉在麻醉般的枕头上。我的眼皮紧闭。失明会阻碍我的行动。我的手臂和双腿记住了烙印在感官记忆中的沉重金属，拒绝给我度过这一天所需的优雅。我的身体拒绝运作，这是为了生存。如果我移动，意味着我得起床。如果我起床，我可能会洗澡、穿衣。如果我做了这些，我就得去工作，去面对那无法言说、难以想象的恐惧。
Now, don't get me wrong. I have nothing against work per se. The concept of joining shoulder-to-shoulder with efficient, enthusiastic coworkers, discovering problems, crafting solutions, pushing onward, always onward via honest sweat of brow is attractive to me. I think of well-constructed women in business suits, the ones who really know how to tie a scarf, dashing through airports to catch that last flight to Rome, manhandling a potential empire crashing crisis, and spending an exhausted yet satisfied overnight in the company pensione.
现在，别误会我。我并不反感工作本身。与高效、热情的同事并肩作战，发现问题，制定方案，推陈出新，始终通过额头上的辛勤汗水不断前进，这个概念对我很有吸引力。我想到那些穿着职业套装、干练的女性，那些真正懂得如何系丝巾的人，她们穿梭在机场赶往罗马的最后一班航班，应对可能导致帝国崩溃的危机，在公司旅馆里度过疲惫却满足的一夜。
I think of post office murals and 1950's communist propaganda. Strong, textured, geometric men in the stoic blue of the overall and the work shirt, reverently folding open the land, courageously braving the hell of the forge, lifting their ruddy cheeks and angular chins to God or government, simply, deeply, thankful for their job. That was work to me, not the salaried conflagration I went to every day.
我想到邮局的壁画和 1950 年代的共产主义宣传。那些穿着工装裤和工装衬衫、线条硬朗的强壮男人，虔诚地开拓土地，勇敢地面对熔炉的地狱，将红润的脸颊和棱角分明的下巴抬向神明或政府，仅仅是深深地感谢自己的工作。那才是我心中的工作，而不是我每天去的那种领工资的灾难。
I worked at a small trade journal in the suburbs where I handled various layout and writing tasks. It was a tiny firm, a mom and pop organization, if you will, starring Leona Helmsley as mom. The publisher was a shrunken, shrewish woman in her 50's, the kind of woman who thought the word "broad" was a badge of honor. She fancied herself the last of the old Chicago newsies, barking her wisdom from her stuffy, windowless office, her cover sticks sweating off the gin blossoms in her nose, one of an endless supply of beige stained Virginia Slims dangling from her lipless mouth.
我在郊区的一家小型贸易期刊工作，负责各种排版和写作任务。那是一家小公司，如果可以的话，就是那种“夫妻店”，由利昂娜·赫尔姆斯利担任“严母”。出版商是一位五十多岁、萎缩而刻薄的女人，那种认为“荡妇”这个词是荣誉勋章的女人。她自诩为最后一位老派芝加哥报贩，在她那闷热、没有窗户的办公室里咆哮着智慧，她的遮瑕膏掩盖不住鼻子上因酗酒留下的酒渣，嘴里总是叼着一支没完没了的米黄色 Virginia Slims 香烟。
Her motto was this-- yell, yell, and yell some more. If they're there the next morning, you've lost your touch. It was as if Satan had made a foray into human resources. She stood over my shoulder constantly, criticizing my work with raptorial fervor, waiting like a blood-mouthed hyena for the moment when I tripped up and made an error. And when I did screw up, as employees inevitably do when told they can do nothing else, she was all over me like drone bees to the queen. I was not capable of being right. The presumption that I could be right, that I could even have an opinion, infuriated her. Any argument I sputtered in my defense was dissected, mocked, and negated. After all, how can one question the wisdom of a woman who cornered the floral industry tabloid market? It was better to tip my neck open and let her drink.
她的座右铭是——大喊大叫，再大喊大叫。如果他们第二天早上还在，说明你还没失准。这简直就像是撒旦对人力资源部门的一次突袭。她不断地站在我身后，以一种贪婪的热情批评我的工作，像一只嘴角带血的鬣狗一样等待着我出错的那一刻。而当我确实搞砸了——正如被告知什么都做不好的人必然会做的那样——她就像雄蜂围攻蜂王一样围攻我。我无法做对任何事。我居然认为自己能做对，甚至能有自己的观点，这让她感到愤怒。我为辩护而说出的任何话都被她剖析、嘲弄和否定。毕竟，怎么能质疑一个垄断了花卉行业小报市场的女人的智慧呢？还不如直接切开脖子让她喝血。
As horrible as it was, I couldn't just leave. She paid me $12,000 a year. Even with a second job on weekends, I barely got by. I rarely went out anywhere. I felt like restaurants were meant for other people. The world seemed to narrow to the places where I could and could not go. My friends nicknamed me Florence Nightingale. No one could nurse a drink like I could. I bought the cheapest food possible, the cheapest clothes available, and forgot about cutting my hair. My thought process was consistently reduced to the bottom line. Basically, the job taught me one thing-- how to live a life with little or no option. And after a while, I was incapable of imagining myself in any other circumstance. Forget about my college degree and all the experience I obtained. This was how it was and always would be. If you thought about it too much, it became hard to breathe.
尽管这很可怕，但我不能就这么离开。她一年付给我 12,000 美元。即使周末有第二份工作，我也勉强糊口。我很少去任何地方。我觉得餐馆是为别人准备的。世界似乎缩小到我能去和不能去的地方。朋友们给我起了个外号叫“南丁格尔”。没人能像我那样熬日子。我买最便宜的食物，穿最便宜的衣服，连理发都忘了。我的思维过程持续地降格为底线。基本上，这份工作只教会了我一件事——如何过一种几乎没有选择的生活。过了一段时间，我无法想象自己身处任何其他环境中。忘记我的大学学位和获得的所有经验吧。事实就是这样，而且永远会是这样。如果你想得太多，连呼吸都变得困难。
The breaking came when review time rolled around, two months later than she said it would when she hired me. She told me she wasn't going to give me a raise. Raises were given on merit in her office, she said. My work did not merit a raise. The room was suddenly very literally light. It was almost too bright in the room to look at her without wincing. I could hear the hum of the office lamps. I was amazed at my calm. I stood, walked to my desk, took my office keys off the chain, and walked out the door.
爆发发生在绩效评估时，比她雇我时说的时间晚了两个月。她告诉我，她不会给我加薪。她说，在她的办公室里，加薪是看表现的。我的工作不值得加薪。房间突然变得非常明亮。房间里亮得让人睁不开眼，甚至无法直视她。我能听到办公室灯管的嗡嗡声。我对自己感到震惊，我竟然如此冷静。我站起来，走到办公桌前，从链子上取下办公室钥匙，然后走出大门。
I did not know what I was going to do and, blessedly, I did not care. I sat quietly on the train back to the city, feeling my back muscles slowly unravel and my stomach lift six inches into my heart. The warmth started in my cheeks and spread down to my fingers, down to my feet. My lungs expanded completely, which hurt a bit. It felt like I had been swimming all day and had forgotten to breathe. I didn't mind the pain. Peace is a fine travelling companion.
我不知道自己要做什么，但幸运的是，我不在乎。我安静地坐在回城的火车上，感觉到背部肌肉慢慢放松，胃部向上提了六英寸，贴近了心脏。温暖从脸颊开始，蔓延到手指，蔓延到脚趾。我的肺部完全舒展了，这还有点疼。感觉就像我游了一整天的泳，忘了呼吸。我不介意这种疼痛。宁静是一个很好的旅伴。
Lisa Buscani. More from her in a minute. But first this song from Robert Metrick, first performed in Chicago's Club Lower Lengths. You're listening to Your Radio Playhouse.
丽莎·布斯卡尼。一会儿还有更多她的内容。但首先是这首来自罗伯特·梅特里克的歌，首次在芝加哥的 Club Lower Lengths 表演。你正在收听的是《你的广播剧场》。
[MUSIC - "THE CALENDAR SONG" BY ROBERT METRICK]
[音乐 - 罗伯特·梅特里克的《日历之歌》]
Part two, Love.
第二部分，爱。
When we started, he and I, I was thin. My face was a diamond, all clean walls. Nothing held me back. Not my clothes, not my lack of money. I was weightless but I had control, like astronauts after they learn to swim properly in space.
刚开始的时候，我和他，我很瘦。我的脸像一颗钻石，轮廓清晰。没有什么能阻挡我。不是我的衣服，也不是我没钱的事实。我处于失重状态，但我拥有控制权，就像宇航员学会如何在太空中游泳之后一样。
Our conversations used to overlap and dovetail and interweave, and occasionally we'd stop to breathe. Great pictures of limitless futures, expensive and unfettered. That's how we talked it. I tried to break my visions down to see how to make them happen and he just made his bigger, which is one way of doing it, I guess.
我们的谈话曾经重叠、衔接、交织，偶尔我们停下来喘口气。关于无限未来的宏伟图景，昂贵且不受束缚。我们就是这样谈论的。我试着把我的憧憬拆解开来，看看如何实现它们，而他只是把他的憧憬放大，我想这也是一种方式。
When we made love, we knew how to forget ourselves. That, I'm convinced, is passion. To kiss him so hard and hold him so hard that the act itself is forgotten. And all that is remembered is skin and hair and warmth. That's a gift. That's something we kept for a long, long time.
当我们做爱时，我们知道如何忘记自我。我坚信，这就是激情。紧紧地拥吻他，以至于动作本身都被遗忘了。剩下的只有皮肤、头发和温暖。那是一份礼物。那是我们保留了很长很长时间的东西。
The decline was relatively slow. Every time we fought, I took the opportunity to shift the relationship from one shoulder to another just to give myself a break and better balance. And we'd start again. I had carried us a long time. He could say that, too, I suppose.
衰退是相对缓慢的。每次我们争吵，我都会抓住机会把这段关系从一个肩膀换到另一个肩膀，只是为了给自己一个喘息的机会，保持平衡。然后我们又重新开始。我背负了我们很长一段时间。我想他也可以这么说。
I started gaining weight, and that seemed to be the theme of it. It became harder and harder to get down to the bone. The way we were put together began to escape me. When we made love, we suddenly knew exactly where we were and what was going on. It was one of those great sadnesses that you carry in your throat.
我开始发胖，这似乎成了主题。想要触及本质变得越来越难。我们结合在一起的方式开始离我而去。当我们做爱时，我们突然清楚地知道我们在哪里，发生了什么。那是你喉咙里承载的巨大悲伤之一。
I couldn't quit it because this was one so easy. On the morning of the first night he stayed with me, I woke up and looked at him and found home. I could fold myself into him, into the warmth found in those deco corners.
我无法放弃它，因为这段关系曾经如此简单。在他和我共处的第一晚后的早晨，我醒来看着他，找到了家的感觉。我可以让自己融入他，融入那些装饰角落里发现的温暖。
I couldn't quit it because I had been alone much of my life. To be alone again meant an energy my aging had confiscated. And even though I was still alone with him, a future was the crumb of consolation.
我无法放弃它，因为我生命的大部分时间都是孤独的。再次孤独意味着一种我随着年龄增长而丧失的能量。尽管我和他在一起时仍然感到孤独，但未来却是一点点安慰。
I couldn't quit it because it didn't fit the only picture I had. My parents knew the necessary work of love. They were the model here. If they could work dogged for their heart, so could I, I thought.
我无法放弃它，因为它不符合我唯一拥有的图景。我的父母知道爱的必要工作。他们是这里的榜样。我想，如果他们能为了彼此的心而顽强地努力，我也能。
I couldn't quit it because of winter. I can't stand to sleep alone in the cold.
我无法放弃它，因为冬天。我无法忍受在寒冷的夜晚独自睡觉。
The end happened several times, actually. We would inevitably hook up again and mess around. We just didn't look in each other's eyes is all. One night we were eating dinner and his smile was less than honest. And I thought, well, then this is it. I said, I've been working far too hard for far too long. And he agreed, and I wanted him to fight it, and was disappointed by how light he was. Smiling, so ready to fly. I felt light, too, but it was the way you are before you catch a cold, all unfocused and buzzing. And the chill comes from inside.
结束其实发生了好几次。我们不可避免地会再次复合，继续纠缠。我们只是不再直视对方的眼睛而已。一天晚上我们正在吃晚饭，他的笑容显得不那么真诚。我想，嗯，就是这样了。我说，我工作得太努力太久了。他同意了，我本希望他能反抗，但他表现得如此轻盈，让我感到失望。微笑着，随时准备飞走。我也感到轻盈，但这就像你感冒前的那种状态，晕乎乎的，嗡嗡作响。那种寒冷来自内心。
Lisa Buscani.
丽莎·布斯卡尼。
Dwight Okita has this poem about quitting from his book Crossing with the Light . He wrote it back when he worked as a dance instructor. It's about a student he became friends with.
德怀特·奥基塔在他的书《随光穿行》中有一首关于放弃的诗。这是他当舞蹈教练时写的。那是关于他的一位朋友学生。
Somewhere in Chicago, a woman unplugs a toaster from a wall, and suddenly her apartment is empty. She wraps the cord jump rope style into a bow, lowers the appliance into a box marked "Kitchen Things," and tapes it shut. All day, boxes move past her, a brown blur against the white walls. How many men does it take to lift a woman's spirits?
在芝加哥的某个地方，一个女人拔掉了墙上的烤面包机插头，突然她的公寓空了。她把电线像跳绳一样绕成一个蝴蝶结，把电器放进标着“厨房用品”的盒子里，然后用胶带封好。整天，箱子从她身边移过，白墙映衬出一道棕色的模糊影像。要多少男人才能振奋一个女人的精神？
"Make your arms like a barrel," I scolded, your dance instructor, fox-trotting you around the room. "Women are always walking backwards, aren't they?" you said, looking at your feet. And I spun you. "No, just going in circles." And here we laughed. In the mirrors of the dance studio, we laughed. And I saw us, lost in the fun house again. I want it always to be fun.
“把你的双臂摆成桶状，”作为舞蹈教练的我责备道，带着你在房间里跳狐步舞。“女人总是倒着走，不是吗？”你看着自己的脚说道。我让你旋转起来。“不，只是在绕圈子。”我们大笑起来。在舞蹈室的镜子里，我们大笑。我看着我们，再次迷失在游乐场里。我希望它永远如此有趣。
Now everything is loaded on the truck. She sits behind the wheel of something larger than her. "I'm going to Timbuktu and I'm taking my time," she says her hands on the wheel. "Peaches, pears, apples, plums. Tell me when your birthday comes." And I wave to her from the curb.
现在一切都装上了卡车。她坐在一辆比她大得多的驾驶座后面。“我要去廷巴克图，我会慢慢来，”她双手握着方向盘说。“桃子、梨子、苹果、李子。告诉我你的生日是什么时候。”我从路边向她挥手。
It paints a sad picture, this woman in a van pulling out of a driveway no longer hers. And for her, I do a farewell samba on the lawn, alone, taking the darkness in the crescent of my arms, leading it in a dance I'm just beginning to learn.
这描绘了一幅悲伤的画面，这个女人开着货车驶出一个不再属于她的车道。而对她，我在草坪上独自跳起告别的桑巴，拥抱怀抱中那弯弯的黑暗，引领着它跳起我刚开始学习的舞蹈。
"The Farewell Samba" by Dwight Okita.
德怀特·冲田（Dwight Okita）的《告别桑巴》。
And we're going to close our broadcast today with a piece by the late Philip Larkin, which seems perfect as you contemplate upcoming quits. Over the course of the next week, we're not quitting anything. I think that's what you've gotten out of this particular program. Anyway, this is called "Poetry of Departures."
节目最后，我们将以已故诗人菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）的一首诗作为结束，这首诗似乎非常适合你在思考即将到来的离职时阅读。在接下来的一周里，我们不会放弃任何事情。我想这就是你们从这个特定节目中得到的启示。总之，这首诗名为《离别的诗意》。
Sometimes you hear, fifth-hand/ As epitaph/ He chucked up everything and just cleared off,/ And always the voice will sound/ Certain you approve/ This audacious, purifying,/ Elemental move.
有时你从第五手传闻中听闻/ 作为墓志铭/ 他抛弃了一切，孑然一身远走高飞/ 而那声音总是听起来/ 笃定你会赞赏/ 这种大胆、纯粹/ 本原的举动。
And they are right, I think./ We all hate home/ And having to be there/ I detect my room,/ It's specially-chosen junk,/ The good books, the good bed,/ And my life, in perfect order/ So to hear it said/
我想，他们说得对。/ 我们都讨厌家/ 讨厌不得不待在那里/ 我审视着我的房间/ 那些精挑细选的破烂/ 好书，好床/ 以及我那井井有条的生活/ 所以当听到那句/
He walked out on the whole crowd/ Leaves me flushed and stirred,/ Like Then she undid her dress/ Or Take that, you bastard;/ Surely I can, if he did?/ And that helps me stay/ Sober and industrious./ But I'd go today,/
他抛下众人离去/ 让我感到面红耳赤，心潮澎湃/ 就像“然后她解开了裙子”/ 或“接招吧，你这混蛋”；/ 他能做到，我当然也能，不是吗？/ 那让我保持/ 清醒和勤奋。/ 但我今天就会走，/
Yes, swagger the nut-strewn roads,/ Crouch in the fo'c'sle/ Stubbly with goodness, if/ It weren't so artificial,/ Such a deliberate step backwards/ To create an object/ Books; china; a life/ Reprehensibly perfect.
是的，在撒满坚果的路上大步流星，/ 蜷缩在船头/ 满脸胡茬，充满善意，如果/ 这不是如此虚假，/ 不是为了创造某种客体/ 而刻意倒退一步/ 书籍；瓷器；一种/ 无可指责的完美生活。
There's so many famous quits. There's so many quits that have driven world history.
有太多著名的离职案例。有太多的离职行为推动了世界历史的发展。
I'm Ira Glass. See you next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。下周再见，届时将有更多《美国生活》（This American Life）的故事。